All right.
So you may be asking yourself,
why are we reading the confessions?
I think I gave a preliminary answer before,
but um,
since it seems to be perhaps more appropriate for religious studies or
philosophy.
Let me remind you why we're struggling through this.
First,
the impact of Christianity on the Roman Empire.
That is to say the sort of social and intellectual setting of the rise of
Christianity in the late fourth,
early fifth century.
The second is,
uh,
to understand some of the Christian moral and doc tank trinal problems and their
implications.
Once again,
we're not exactly interested in these for reasons of theology or morality,
but we need to get into the minds of people at the time in order to understand
what bothered them,
what controversies they were involved in,
how those controversies indeed divided the Roman Empire and the successors to
the Roman Empire.
Some of those problems,
well under the know that second heading of Christian moral and doctrinal
problems.
Uh,
let me just mention three,
which by no means exhausts them,
but our three that we can sort of,
if not identify with,
I think see their importance.
One,
the problem of evil.
Second,
the relation between body and soul.
Okay.
And three,
the Christian Understanding of sin and redemption.
Now it turns out these are all aspects of the same problem
and they are dealt with in Augustine's works most thoroughly,
more thoroughly than any other thinker of the ancient world.
The third reason we're looking at this is the interaction between Christianity
and classical culture and religion,
Roman life and politics,
Augustine's career.
And he's giving up his career what that means.
Uh,
other ideas within the Roman empire such as [inaudible],
Platonism.
And then finally,
this is a document of philosophical and psychological investigation.
And while that is not our primary purpose here,
uh,
you should not get out of a liberal arts college program without reading this
and pondering it a little.
This,
uh,
can be summarized in terms of the importance of the humanities even or of
philosophical investigation as opposed to mere investigation of natural
phenomena in words that Augustine uses in book 10,
which we have not read after book nine.
Book 10 is a turning.
It discusses time and the meaning of time.
Books.
11,
12 and 13 are a commentary on genesis worth reading.
Uh,
if you like an interesting to think about how they do or do not mesh with the
more confessional parts of the confession.
But in book 10,
he says,
um,
men go out and gays in astonishment at high mountains,
the huge waves of the sea,
the broad reaches of rivers,
the ocean that in circles the world or the stars in their courses,
but they pay no attention to themselves.
They are busy looking at external phenomena and not examining their own heart.
And if the confessions is anything,
it is certainly an examination of the authors heart,
but it's not an examination of his heart in a purely emotional sense in the way
we're familiar with in so-called confessional literature.
I had a tough upbringing.
This happened to me,
that happened to me.
Uh,
I struggled with addiction.
I,
uh,
you know,
beat my kids.
Now I'm a great person.
Uh,
whatever.
this is an intellectual investigation as well as an emotional investigation.
And indeed,
Augustine doesn't see these as separate or to the degree that he does.
It's in a more complicated way than just saying intellectual versus not an
intellectual.
He is an intellectual obviously,
and he awakened to being an intellectual experience that many of you may have
had member.
He reads this dialogue by Cicero now lost,
called the Hortencia's.
And this convinces him that the life of the mind is the most important thing to
pursue.
And I wouldn't say that we all have had this experience,
but maybe,
uh,
you,
what was the point at which you discovered that you weren't like other people
but they lived more for immediate sensations or pleasure or what Augustine would
call debauchery,
uh,
and you wanted to read or think about stuff or,
you know,
uh,
do lab experiments.
I think the essence of Yale,
if I understand it correctly,
is I don't have to choose between fun and the intellectual life,
but,
um,
so it's not actually perhaps relevant to your lives now,
but,
uh,
particularly if you went to a public high school,
grew up in a non intellectual environment,
uh,
you know,
those of you whose parents are professors and I went to some school where,
everybody was reading Latin at the age of six.
I'm not talking to you,
but I'm talking to the vast majority who woke up one day and realized,
uh,
either with pride or with dismay,
I'm different from other people.
Ideas have meaning to me.
Ah,
I'm going to suffer in life for that though.
They're going to be some rewards and I leave you to discern what the rewards are
and to mull over what the suffering has been.
Or maybe we'll continue to be,
I hope not.
Uh,
and I suspect,
um,
you'll have an easier time of it.
But this book is about a search for truth and they searched the,
takes a number of,
um,
wrong turns,
at least from Augustine's opinion.
Looking back on the situation when he wrote this in the three,
nine days.
It's a confession of sin.
It's also,
as I said before,
a confession of praise for the God who is love directed him back to the right
path.
It is personal but exemplary.
It is about spiritual yearning,
but it is also about intellectual yearning for truth.
Okay?
It's a book about the education of a young man and the adventures of this young
man and what he learns from them.
Now in the first place,
he is both an intellectual and a passionate person.
He is someone who is a unusually frank about his desires,
but notice that he's not just opposed to desire.
He is not someone who believes that desire,
love,
uh,
are to be simply repressed or ignored.
Love is a psychological need.
And he has a very discerning,
an interesting passage in describing his teenage years and his lusts.
Uh,
when he,
um,
uh,
frequented the Bravos of Carthage in book three,
at the beginning,
he says,
I was in love with the idea of love.
She was not only in love,
but he was in love with the idea of being an emotional being of a love that is
both sexual and spiritual in which they're in.
These two things are not well marked off from each other.
He is also a believer in friendship.
And it's funny because in our own culture,
I think friendship has changed.
Uh,
when I started teaching,
people had trouble dealing with the affection that he has for his friends,
like Olympias and the Bredius or the mysterious unnamed friend who dies after
being baptized.
Uh,
Augustine is always surrounded by friends.
Even in the most intimate moments when he's undergoing this conversion.
There are all sorts of people right around him.
Uh,
and as I said before,
this seemed to be,
I mean,
the explanation was,
well,
he must've been homosexual or any young,
you must have these,
uh,
these desires.
Or maybe it's part of Roman culture of friendship.
But,
uh,
in recent decades or years where we have a culture of friendship where your
friends are extremely important,
admittedly,
if you have 900 of them,
uh,
it's a little bit perhaps weekend.
But I think we can understand some of this better than might have been the case
a little while ago.
This friend who dies,
uh,
after being baptized here is an example of another form of seriousness.
Uh,
they go out and have fun together.
The friend becomes ill,
the friend is suddenly very serious.
The friend gets baptized because to be baptized as with Constantine means that
you are committing yourself to a much more stringent and moral life then,
uh,
before
and then he dies and there's certainly disturbs.
Augustine.
What,
what is life all about?
Any of you who've had the experience of,
uh,
contemporaries of yours who have died,
will understand this.
Augustine's is also ambitious.
He is a successful person even though he's from a modest family.
His father,
a,
um,
a pagan or non Christian,
middle class,
a official of North Africa,
his mother,
a Christian,
he's clearly marked for success because of his unusual gifts is unusual gifts
being a intellectual ability to write,
the ability to argue.
He's marked out as extremely smart.
And at that time,
success,
uh,
for such a person,
the course of success was through government service.
This is the era of post Diocletian Post Constantine.
Um,
and related particularly to a combination of rhetoric and law says not all that
different from society's familiar to us.
That is to say the training and law gives one access to a number of different
kinds of political offices,
but rhetoric is perhaps a little stranger to us.
Rhetoric in this context means the art of persuasion.
So it's very closely related to law and legal pleading.
It is the art of writing well of writing elegantly and it is very,
very highly valued in the Roman empire.
His mother,
Monica is extremely pious.
In fact,
the first section of class rather than I taught,
um,
no,
I guess I was a section leader right when I was a graduate student.
The first,
the first section I had,
um,
my students were arguing with me about Augustine's patronizing attitude towards
his mother.
And I said,
well,
no,
you know,
he's not patronizing.
He's,
you know,
he's smarter than his mother.
And,
uh,
um,
he's,
uh,
you know,
he's gone.
His mother is just an ordinary person.
After all,
Augustine becomes a saint and his mother doesn't attend.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
a guy from Santa Monica Catholic school,
uh,
sending,
Oh,
who do you think Santa Monica is?
Um,
this is Augustine's mother.
So anyway,
I've learned,
uh,
Augustine's mother is saying she is a more steadfast kind of person than August
and he's not someone who stays up all night wrestling with the problem of evil.
Nevertheless,
she does not want him to be baptized.
She wants him to be successful.
Like most mothers,
she wants her child to be a good person,
but even more than that,
she wants her child to be a success.
And that means delaying baptism because if he's going to be a success,
he's going to have to be involved in the world of high government.
And that may mean well,
that definitely means
involvement in sinfulness,
uh,
involvement in the shedding of blood involvement in legal wrangling and stuff
like that.
And so,
um,
he is encouraged to lead a normal life,
normal in meaning,
at least in his own retrospective view,
sinful life.
This is what Augustine has given up in his conversion.
He is giving up a career.
He is giving up a social expectation of success or social definition of success.
He is giving up the pleasures attendant on that career,
which range from parties to honors to sexual conquests,
uh,
and the whole life of a well established member of the Roman elite.
Okay.
What is bothering Augustine?
What bothers him is in part the,
um,
problem of evil.
We've alluded to already,
why a good and omnipotent God allow evil to flourish?
A related problem is that compared to the works of the Greek writers and
philosophers,
the Bible seems awfully crude to him.
Rhetorically in terms of style and conceptually in terms of its ideas.
Be Old Testament God.
And you know,
we're probably at various levels of familiarity with the Old Testament,
but the old testament God is,
um,
temperamental.
I think it's fair to say,
here's the guy who decides to destroy God,
a deity who does strives to destroy the world by flood,
uh,
destroys the cities of the plain,
um,
kills one of the people bearing the a tabernacle back to uh,
a Jerusalem because he stumbles.
Um,
God is this,
this bothers Augustine and his anthropomorphism bothers Augustine in the Old
Testament,
in the Hebrew Bible of God speaks with people.
Uh,
Adam hears him walking in the garden.
How can that be?
How can this,
uh,
um,
human seeming God be the Real God?
So these two anxieties put Augustine in the camp of the mannequins member.
The mannequins believe that the solution to the problem of evil is that God is
not omnipotent.
God is trying,
but there's another evil God who is opposing him.
And that evil God is the god of the flesh and the god of the Old Testament to
Hova the creator God,
the God of matter and flesh.
We are souls imprisoned in flush.
Our true home is the spiritual.
And we have to renounce everything that has to do with the flesh in order to go
there.
So mannequin is and would seem to be extremely ascetic.
You should have absolutely nothing to do with the world.
But as is always the case with the statement,
everything that's material is evil,
but we are material.
Mannequin aneurysm also offers or affords you an opportunity to be completely
involved in the world,
totally involved in the world because there's nothing you can do about it.
All you can do is say the flushes evil.
I'm in the flesh.
I'm just having to deal with it until uh,
I am liberated into the spirit.
So Mannequin Ism is not necessarily world renouncing,
but they do identify the source of evil with the body.
The body is wicked.
The immaterial soul is good.
This is not Christianity as Augustine,
uh,
discovers or elaborates.
Even though we may think of Christianity as exalting the soul over the body.
Nevertheless,
it also exalts the body.
The Christian doctrine is that the bodies of,
uh,
human beings will be resurrected,
not just the souls.
There will be bodies after the last judgment in heaven and in Hell.
God created the world and it was good.
What then explains the presence of evil.
Augustine at this stage turns to Platonism for an understanding of the nature of
evil.
Evil is not a thing in itself.
It is rather the absence of good.
Now,
if anyone has ever said that to you,
you will have found that unconvincing,
at least in its first iteration,
because we're not just talking about the absence of good as in this bowl of
Chili is not very good.
It's not very flavorful.
It's okay,
but it's kind of lacking in something.
But that's not evil.
Evil is not kind of like not particularly good.
Evil is much more vivid,
gratuitous,
cruel,
all encompassing.
The Platonists don't deny that what they mean by saying it's the privation of
good is that it is nothingness.
Evil is in fact the absence of being and meaning.
The reason it produces such spectacular effects as war
oppression,
crime
is that people turn away from the good or they turn away from what is truly good
to prefer lower goods.
They turn away from the things of the spirit to the things of the flesh.
They prefer their own lusts and desires,
their own ambitions.
And greed to the common good or to the immaterial and spiritual good and it's
this turning away from the sun is turning away from good.
That seems to be a human problem.
Human beings,
generally speaking,
don't understand what they are on earth for.
According to the Platonists,
many of you are familiar with the metaphor of the cave from the republic.
This is the classic depiction of this wrong preference.
The people in the cave are chained facing the back wall of the cave and they see
images of what's passing in front of the cave reflected on the wall.
As time goes on,
they come to believe that those images are reality.
They forget that their chain,
they forget that they can't see the real things.
They forget the Sun.
If you were to liberate them and turn them around and show them the light,
first of all,
they couldn't bear it because they're used to the world of shadow.
Secondly,
they kill you because you are destroying their assumptions and their world.
They would at least persecute you.
Yeah,
they're not interested in the truth.
They're interested in getting by.
So for the Platonists evil is the result of this error in perception.
Assuming that it's a great thing to get rich or assuming that it's a great thing
to uh,
beat people up because you're stronger than they are,
uh,
or it's a great thing to um,
conquer and subjugate or all of these things,
some of which are evil,
but are really the preference of things that you should not be pursuing or that
you should be pursuing for reasons inspired by spiritual
truth.
How do you get rid of this and the Platonist imagination by education.
That's the whole point of Plato's dialogues.
That's why they are dialogs.
Many of them with a kind of question and answer.
They're very didactic.
They're like being in a class,
Socrates quizzes people,
and then he shows the solution and they say,
Oh wow,
software these.
Now I understand.
Now I'm going to be a Platonist and I'm going to build a perfect society and
live story.
Okay?
The important thing to understand about Platonism is that it is not dualist in
the way that mannequin ism is,
or the way that we sort of instinctively think about evil.
Evil is not opposed to good.
It's hierarchically inferior to good
the Platonists universes like a ladder with many rungs going up from mud bugs,
rocks to the immaterial one,
and with many,
many steps.
As I said,
many runs or steps or levels in between.
Human beings are kind of in the middle and also human beings,
unlike animals,
mud slugs,
but also unlike angels and Demi urges and D at Hays human beings can move up and
down the ladder.
That's what free will is.
That's what being human,
you can read Hortencia's breed the confessions,
um,
fall in love with the liberal arts and descend to some very high realm of the
spirit or,
uh,
you know,
you can choose to the downward path to debauchery and mere pleasure.
It's a question of how free you are,
but you do,
we do have the opportunity to move up and down this ladder.
Unlike the animals and other create all of the creative forces that are fixed.
Now question is what makes us move up and down this or what will motivate us to
move up.
Yeah.
And here we come to some key differences between Platonism and Christianity.
With regard to evil.
Platonism tends to ascribe evil to ignorance.
Christianity's tends to ascribe evil to sin.
The difference between sin and ignorance is that,
um,
sin is deliberate.
You know,
you shouldn't do this and you do it anyway.
You're not overcome by desire.
So to anticipate one of the paper topics,
but I don't think I'm going to be giving away the answer.
What is it about the pair stealing incident that makes it so important?
Anybody want to venture a preliminary response to this?
Well,
it's the fact that he doesn't meet the parents to thought that because he feels
that the center has a desire for you.
So the pairs,
he doesn't need the pairs.
Uh,
it is just a desire.
I mean,
he doesn't say to himself,
I want to sin.
I haven't sinned in two days.
Um,
he doesn't need the pairs.
What did they do with the pairs?
When they get them,
they throw them out.
They throw them to the pigs so they're not hungry.
It's not like I was overcome by desire.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
that led me into some sort of sinful behavior.
They weren't overcome by desire at all.
How would you describe their prepare?
Stealing state?
I mean,
at least what would you guess was there?
Pre pair,
stealing frame of mind?
There's one word that will describe it,
but if you want to use a few more,
some guys go and they steal some pairs from an orchard.
Like fool around with them.
They throw them to the pigs.
Bored,
bored,
bored.
Now here's something we can identify with.
They are bored.
They need to amuse themselves.
They cannot amuse themselves by saying,
I'm a good person or a,
I'm going to the won or a,
I'm going to do some homework.
Ryan.
Uh,
it doesn't end.
Young people are thought to be easily bored.
Uh,
but the boredom of the old people,
it's a,
um,
it's a different kind of board.
I'm,
but there it is.
It's persistent.
That's not the only reason people send.
But it is a gratuitous reason.
And that's what's interesting about the pairs.
It's gratuitous.
It's not from me.
The Platonists don't have a good response to why this happens because it's not a
question of education.
Yeah.
Now Augustine does not invent Christian ideas of sin.
If you said to Augustine,
I've come on,
why are you so worried about the pairs?
He's not worried about the pairs as suck.
It's just a little emblem or a little,
uh,
example of a different kind of problem.
That is to say,
knowing how to behave doesn't change us
feeling how to behave
to put it in Friday in terms it's a,
it's not the uh,
uh,
ego,
but the sides,
it's the Ed instinct,
not the intellect.
And that's what his conversion means.
He's conversion is not,
suddenly I was convinced that Christianity was true.
He already knows that Christianity is true,
but he knows it intellectually.
The conversion is a conversion to an emotional apprehension of it.
So however intellectual he may seem to you,
however,
formed in the tradition of Greco Roman classicism,
he was however much the Hortencia's awakened him to the life of the mind.
He is ultimately a theologian and philosopher of the irrational of the supra
rational.
And indeed,
Christianity in its history has an oscillation between intellectual association
and the rediscovery of Sin and God's grace.
Yeah.
If you think of movements like the reformation of Martin Luther,
John Calvin,
etc. In the 16th century,
it takes issue with the notion that we can do works that give us merit in the
sight of God,
and that the church tells us we have accumulated merits and therefore will go to
heaven.
The reformation teaches that we are face to face with God and that our so called
good deeds don't amount to anything.
We are all sinful.
If God operated according to justice,
we would all go to hell,
faith and grace that save people,
hence the reformation.
But it's also the great awakening of Britain and America in the 18th century is
the development of methodism.
Um,
the fundamentalist,
a,
a movement,
all of these tend to reject attempts to approach God contractually attempts to
approach God in terms of a deal.
So
if human beings are sinful
and if education is not going to get them out of sin,
what will,
okay.
Now the Augustine of the confessions is different than the Augustine of 20 years
later when he wrote the city of God and we're not studying the city of God,
but,
um,
uh,
this book written in response to the sack of Rome in four 10.
Yeah,
develop some ideas that are found in the confessions about the nature of sin and
how we get out of it.
The nature of sin is the pairs.
How we get out of it is at least in part the conversion.
We got the pairs sufficiently for the time being.
The conversion is started,
well,
it started long before the event,
but what precipitates it as a drama is this conversation with Ponti Sianna's in
book eight,
part eight,
who has traveled
and describes the monks of Egypt.
Now we'll be talking lots and lots about monks.
But the monks of Egypt are the first example of Christian monks.
Men who flee the world into the desert and they are,
you know,
live on,
uh,
you know,
weeds,
uh,
a sight line,
water,
locusts,
other insects,
basically nothing.
Uh,
and they,
uh,
they have visions and they are sought out by ordinary people.
It's key to understand that to be a hermit in this society does not necessarily
mean that you have nothing to do with pink bowl.
People start to want to find you because you must have special power
back in Alexandria,
their baby is sick.
Maybe you,
oh hermit living on locus and out in the desert had some spiritual power to help
my baby.
This is shamanism.
It happens in all sorts of religions.
You can't just be a shaman or medicine man,
a wise man and hold down a regular old job or you can.
But it helps.
And that's the conceit of a lot of TV ideas.
You know,
secret heroes there.
They're real estate agents,
but they're battling the forces of darkness.
But generally,
most of the time you've got to be special and you've got to look special and
you've got to be a reject.
You can't have a spouse,
kids,
a mortgage,
a garden,
a swing set.
You've got a,
B,
a c,
or you've got to have your vision focused on the other world.
Pontius Yanas tells Augustine about these men,
and his response is not only to be impressed by them,
but to be humiliated by them.
First of all,
here are these guys who are
intoxicated with God.
While I'm still thinking about my career,
but,
and this is the ancient world speaking.
They are uneducated.
These monks of Egypt,
they didn't study the republic,
the hort 10 cs,
the Timaeus,
the rhetoric of quintillion.
The satire is a juvenile.
They don't know anything about this.
They're uneducated people.
The many of them are illiterate,
and yet they are closer to God.
They have an apprehension of the divine that causes them to renounce the world,
whereas we Augustine says of him and his circle,
we,
uh,
um,
lie here,
groveling in this world of flesh and blood while they storm the gates of heaven.
And this is the moment of his conversion.
Yeah.
Now,
after his conversion,
Augustine's plan was to lead a life of contemplation with his friends.
They would retreat from the world,
meaning they would give up their careers,
but it would be a little bit like,
um,
you and your friends,
one of your friend's parents have a lot of money and have this wonderful cabin,
uh,
somewhere in the Rockies or the sawtooth mountains.
And you're going to figure out some kind of way of,
uh,
you know,
you'll be on the internet and everything,
but,
but you're gonna,
you're gonna,
um,
have this kind of beautiful contemplative life.
But the beautiful part is that it's not going to be uncomfortable.
It's not the desert of Egypt.
It's remote.
You're not going to be bothered,
but they're beautiful mountains trouts in the stream.
Uh,
you know,
it's a,
it's a sort of idyllic and you and your friends are going to talk about reality
and,
uh,
the spirit and philosophy and,
um,
I dunno how idyllic this sounds to you,
but it's certainly an understandable idea of a way of life.
It is the ancient idea of what's called a leisure with dignity.
And indeed,
that's what being a professor was supposed to be when I signed up for it.
See,
come dignity,
Dante Leisure with dignity,
leisure,
meaning not,
uh,
you know,
wasting time,
leisure,
but not responding to clients or not responding to,
uh,
you know,
urgent scheduling,
phone calls,
a deals you've got to show up to your classes.
Right.
But that's not really honorous.
At least that was the idea.
You know,
wrong.
I won't go into the frustrations of being a professor or the,
the dissatisfactions.
Um,
but the classical ideal is OTM come dignity,
dignity,
meaning not being naked in the desert,
not having to,
you know,
eat locusts and figure out how to,
okay,
I had curry Blokus last night tonight.
I think I'll have,
you know,
locust casserole.
No,
no,
no.
Something nicer than that.
But in fact,
he did not follow through on this.
She did not lead a life of cultivated classical dignity with his friends.
He went back to North Africa.
He became a bishop.
He has years were,
uh,
consumed by disputes over doctrine with heroin.
Anicole as he deemed them tendencies like donatism most notably.
And he died defending his city of hippo,
hippo,
Regius,
um,
in a modern Tunisia from the vandals,
one of those barbarian invaders who will occupy us next week.
He then was very much involved in the world.
To be a bishop in the Roman empire was by no means an office of dignified
leisure.
It was right in there in the political trenches.
It's a position of honor to be sure,
but,
uh,
his understanding of the Christian's duty in the world was that you cannot lead
a life of perfection.
You cannot lead a life of sin free contemplation.
We all are sinners.
He becomes more and more the theologian philosopher who combat perfectionism.
Perfectionism is a doctrine that human beings can be made radically better.
Perfect evening
there,
debates through our societies about the degree of human perfectability.
This is indeed supposedly,
and to some extent,
I think really at the heart of debates between what is called liberalism in the
United States and conservatism.
Liberals believe in human perfectability.
If you educate people,
if you help them,
if you encourage them,
if you provide government subsidies,
you will build a better society.
The response upon the part of conservatives to that is people are the way they
are because,
uh,
that's the way they want to be or they made wrong choices.
Um,
but,
uh,
all the help from some,
you know,
public authority isn't going to help,
isn't going to really make a difference.
Are People perfectible people to believe in education tend to believe that they
are.
On the other hand,
very well educated people have been
bad.
Hitler loved classical music.
So did Stalin.
Just because you are a connoisseur of art doesn't make you a good person.
Augustine is a radical imperfection perfectionist,
more so in the city of God.
Then in the confessions,
which has sort of teetering on the brink,
the pairs as a kind of in perfectionist moment excuses or glimpses,
the power of sin
by the time of the city of God.
By the time that,
uh,
um,
the end of the Roman Empire is at least glimpsed as a possibility and the rise
of the barbarians.
Augustine has become,
uh,
someone who does not believe that human beings can in any way earn salvation.
Human beings are irrevocably sinful.
Once again,
if God judged people according to their merits,
they would all be damned.
Since the Christian belief is that some people are saved,
they're saved by mysterious process called grace.
Grace by its very meaning is undeserved.
You don't show up at the door of heaven with a ticket of admission earned by
your deeds on earth.
What opens the doors to you is a generous,
arbitrary decision.
Well,
generous may mean I had good intentions.
I didn't kill anybody.
Um,
but arbitrary may mean that we can't figure out who's going to heaven and who's
going to hell.
It may even mean that God,
since God knew before we were born,
God predestined us for Heaven or hell.
This is a harsh doctrine.
It gets periodically rediscovered and then dropped.
It's at the heart of the belief of the people who settled Massachusetts and
Connecticut.
It is the heart of Calvinism and puritanism the belief in the elect.
The question is,
are these elect visible or invisible?
The elect are people who are going to go to heaven.
Okay,
are they visible?
Can we say,
this guy is so good,
he's going to heaven.
This woman is so,
uh,
um,
loving,
nurturing,
uh,
self effacing.
When I first she's going to go to heaven.
That's a notion of a visible elect.
An invisible elect is you don't know.
We have no idea.
And this is a crucial difference because if you believe in the visible elect,
even if you say they're not guaranteed,
but anybody outside of the circle is for sure going to hell,
then you have PR,
a Puritan New England,
you have a small community of people pursuing perfection or you have the Amish,
or you have any small Pius community that believes that outside of it is more or
less given over to sin and more or less doomed inside of it.
Maybe it's not guaranteed,
but your chances are much,
much better.
But if you believe
that we don't have a visible elect,
that we have no idea and everybody ought to be in the church,
everybody ought to have access to the sacraments that provide initiation into
the church.
You want to start converting pagans,
even savage pagans,
you ought to be out there roping in as many people into the church,
including people who don't want to be
because you just never know.
Maybe their kids will be,
Augustine is behind ideas of things like forced conversion.
As long as they're baptized,
there's a chance of them being saved and baptized as infants,
preferably because baptism does not any longer mean in Augustine's world
perfection.
It means the beginning.
It means entering the the process.
So the three things that he is teaching that are implicit in the confessions and
that he is important for in terms of his intellectual impact are his opposition
to perfectionism,
his exaltation of Grace
and
the notion of sin as indelible,
not solvable.
Where this becomes a key historical importance is in the church.
The church is a body that can either be sectarian m small as with the Amish or a
puritan New England or it can be huge and universal.
As with the Medieval Catholic Church.
Augustine stands behind the Medieval Catholic church,
which is a political body,
a body of doctrine,
a structure ruled by princes,
and a structure that has a missionary impact on the rest of the world.
Now,
the papers you have,
the paper topics,
if you didn't get them,
come up and see me,
uh,
after,
um,
you can choose any one of them or you can choose something else.
But if you choose something else,
please talk to your teaching fellow or to me and talk to us anyway about these
papers will give you plenty of opportunity to bounce ideas off us.
Now next week we talk about the fall of the Roman empire,
but this is implicit about in what we've talked about today,
because the bottom line is the Roman empire is gonna fall in the West and the
church is not going to.
And so we'll look at how that works next week.
Thanks.